stability security today
is to talk about the war
launched by Russia in Ukraine and on this
subject you have just had
important words and I want here basically
to resume the thread of our exchange
indeed this war of  first of all puts an end to
decades of peace on the
European continent but it is our war
and you called it very well
first of all because a country which is
also a permanent member of the
Security Council has decided to violate the charter
and  we cannot accept this
situation the second thing you have just
recalled with great force
the seriousness and the spirit of responsibility
imposed by nuclear questions
and the desire that France shares that
obviously nuclear power should be
totally excluded from this conflict which is
compliance with all
international treaties on the subject and that under
no circumstances can there be any
deployment of nuclear weapons outside
the territory of nuclear weapons States,
particularly in Europe,
and in this respect everyone must be reminded of
their duties  in particular Russia, which
announced and for a few days wanted to
deploy such weapons in Belarus,
which is not in accordance with the commitments
made to you, to us and to
international law,
Russian aggression in Ukraine has dealt a
blow to this stability, it has  put an end to
decades of peace in Europe and I
know I can count on you, moreover, in respect of the
two principles I
have just mentioned to
bring Russia to its senses and
everyone to the negotiating table and
we will come back to this  in detail, but
we need to find a
lasting peace, that is to say a peace that
respects
internationally recognized borders and
avoids any form of escalation, and I believe
that this is also an important issue
for China as much  that it is for
France and for Europe
[Music]